bonsoir monsieur sve monsois homonyme
drolet on va commencer par ce guichet
unique d'accès aux soins de première
ligne le pour donner un accès rapide aux
québécois qui n'ont pas de médecin de
famille sont nombreux maintenant pas
loin d'un million donc si vous ne
garantissait pas d'accès mais c'est vous
garantit un accès un professionnel de la
santé vous avez dit soit une infirmière
un pharmacien ça promet être
paramédics donc ce changement de cap on
n'est plus dans les premières soient
médecins de famille pour chaque
québécois on lire dans un professionnel
de la santé pour chaque québécois oui en
fait on s'est ajusté soyons très clairs
on a vécu la pandémie on l'a vu que ce
que les québécois particulièrement dans
les moments difficiles ce qui vous
laisse et avoir accès un professionnel
de la santé de fer c'était par telesur
et c'est aussi un grand changement va le
faire aussi par téléphone alors donc
tout ça pour dire que ce qu'on a vécu
durant la pandémie nous pousse à écouter
des québécois et c'est oui c'est un
changement mais c'est un changement de
ce qu'ils nous ont demandés alors hop on
est mis en place
en 2019
des balbutiements de ce guichet unique
lors dans le bas saint laurent a été
publicisé on a travaillé on l'a amélioré
grâce aux gens le calme c'est un projet
qui n'eut d'une région maintenant
détente reine de l'implanter au québec
puis en résumé si la fin de l'été au
moins la moitié des québécois pourrait y
avoir accès c'est à dire ce que n'auront
pas été pris en charge par la façon
conventionnelle de le faire donc c'est
vraiment une petite révolution que
commencer dans le bas saint laurent mais
qu'on est capable de planter à l'échelle
du québec donc une formule que vous avez
pu tester justement avec ce projet dans
le bas saint laurent mais ceci dit vous
êtes une révolution qu'il ya une
révolution est toujours un petit peu de
résistance aussi parce que des gens dont
le rêve et vous le savez monsieur dubé
c'est d'avoir un médecin de famille
peugeot une infirmière ou un autre
professionnel même s'ils sont très
qualifiés ils veulent bâtir cette
relation de confiance qu'on a avec notre
médecin de famille au fil des ans
quelqu'un qui on peut se confier qui
nous connaît qui est capable de boire à
notre ère
vous n'allez pas bien aujourd'hui mais
c'est parce que vous offrez mais vous
savez vous ce qui est arrivé madame
relais quand on s'est rendu compte les
médecins l'ont apprécié le dur en ce
projet pilote locke commencé il ya deux
ans c'est quand les médecins s'engagent
à prendre dit ce qu'on appelle des
patients orphelins la première fois ils
y prennent puis d'évoquer jeu voir
régler ton problème il faut rester sur
la liste d'attentes mais après deux fois
après trop fort d'une enfant suppose
pire de prendre ce patient l'oeil
beaucoup de ses patients leurs acquis de
cette façon alors on trouver un médecin
de famille avec ce qu'on veut c'est
partir la roue un peu et je pense que ça
crée une relation entre la gmf l'ale de
groupes de médecine familiale la
clinique comme tel et le patient prend
confiance avec cette ligne éclat a été
content des fois d'être servis par une
infirmière ou même par un pharmacien
parce que souvent c'est un
renouvellement de prescriptions que sa
propre c'est difficile de rencontrer le
médecin c'est tout ce qu'on a vécu comme
expérience qui fait que en tout cas
c'est c'est parce qu'on oublie je me
suis sûr les gens venaient en comprend
l'esprit de ce que vous est ici mais la
question c'est ces infirmières vous ces
pharmaciens vous allez prendre nous en
fait bah écoutez la beauté c'est plus le
système fonctionne plus les gens au bout
du travail et il ya déjà par exemple
ceux qui sont sur le gâteau le guichet
d'accès de la première ligne c'est des
gens qui peuvent travailler à partir de
la maison parce que le premier filtre se
fait par téléphone alors passez
conseille beaucoup de personnes âgées
qui veulent parler directement sur le
web ou par exemple on veut avoir pour
quelqu'un qui est non-voyant ya toutes
sortes de raisons pour lesquelles il
déjà qu'ils veulent encore travailler
par le téléphone ou ceux qui travaillent
par le web qui disent voici ma question
toutes les personnes qui peuvent nous
aider être ce premier filtre les guyanes
âge dont on parle c'est déjà qu'ils
peuvent le faire à partir de la maison
donc on a trouvé des gens qui sont
intéressés à faire partie de cette cette
porte d'entrée la ce guichet unique qui
nous permet d'aller chercher des gens
qui veulent pas être dans le réseau dans
un hôpital mais plutôt faire du travail
de consultation comme on a tellement
mais si c'est justement cette personne
là qui est la première ligne mais ton
l'infirmière elle se rend compte que le
patient dans le fond il ya besoin de
médecins donc là on retombe dans un
délai ce délai laisse qui va être cool
bon ça c'est la deuxième partie ce qu'on
est en train d'installer c'en est trop
dans le détail ça aussi ça s'est fait
dans le bas saint laurent c'est d'être
capable de demander aux médecins de le
coupe donc homogène aux médecins qui ont
une clinique une gmf de dire donnez nous
deux à trois pour cent de vous rendez
vous disponible alors quand le guichet
appel puis 10 ou que l'on en a besoin
d'un médecin parce qu'on est sûr on est
certes un pardon que c'est quelqu'un qui
a besoin de vos services
donnez-nous de l'accès à vos
disponibilités de 3% pour un médecin qui
voit 100 patients par semaine c'est
comme lui demander de nous donner deux
trois rendez-vous de plus par semaine
pour être capable de régler le problème
de ce patient qui lui après avoir été
vérifiés ont vraiment besoin d'un
médecin de famille donc le guichet est
là mais déclinées pour continuer à faire
un travail mais avec un filtre qui vont
avoir été voilà rassurés que le patient
vraiment besoin de voir un triage
ans renouvelé une prescription n'a pas
besoin nécessairement de voir son
médecin par contre quand vous parlez de
cette affaire l'un d'eux d'avoir des
médecins finalement qui donne des
disponibilités qui donne des plages
horaires en réalité on sait que c'est un
défi pour vous il ya déjà des guichets
qu'existant pour obtenir le haut niveau
par exemple il ya des résistances chez
les médecins nous ont pas tous donné
leur disponibilité son poteau s'inscrire
il dans les différentes technologies
qu'on a actuellement deux pour essayer
d'animer les patients et les médecins
vous allez faire quoi pour vous assurer
les avez-vous les données sur les
médecins nous y travaillons sur le
projet de loi 11 entre autres qui
voudraient axe-là qui fait quoi combien
ça avance bien ça avance bien je suis
encore l'étude du projet de loi mais
regardez si je faisais la comparaison où
on est l automne dernier septembre
octobre avait beaucoup de discussions on
a beaucoup avancé j'étais capable avec
le nouveau président le docteur à mios
puis son équipe de s'entendre que
justement ça serait plus uniquement un
médecin qui prenait genre de gros
changement pour notre mais on a dit
aussi que la deuxième changement on
allait faire le gap donc saniora
apprécié ces deux changements en échange
mais on est en train de discuter combien
de prise en charge vous pouvez faire de
fer par la gmf donc et la prise de
rendez vous donc c'est certain que les
moins discussions dans le public en ce
moment là on regarde nos discussions
privées moi je trouve que ça avance très
bien on va être capable d'avoir le
succès de je veux dire le succès de
rimouski la est en train de faire des
petits et on va être capable je pensais
d'avancer très vite durant l'été pour
cas pas de
projets en avez-vous toujours besoin oui
j'en ai besoin pour deux raisons 1 parce
que il y aura toujours des gens pour qu
il faut faire l'arrangement on a des
médecins par exemple qui ne sont pas en
clinique privée plus sympa gmf faut
trouver des arrangements pour être
capable de trouver serein de ce ces
rendez-vous additionnels disponibles que
je viens vous explique c'est une chose
mais en fait il ya bien des régions où
on n'a pas besoin de cette partie là
parce que des régions comme rimouski on
peut au besoin du projet doivent donc
c'est pour certains cas spécifiques la
deuxième partie du projet waouh c'est
pour bien comprendre l'offre des
médecins parce que nous au québec
comparé à l'ontario on a beaucoup plus
de médecins de famille qui ont été
formés comme médecin une famille qui ne
prêtent pas comme tel la médecine
générale qui sont par exemple après le
travail et dans une urgence ou et ça il
faut avoir cette donnée là pour bien
comprendre s'ils sont capables de faire
la prise en charge alors moi ce que j'ai
convenu avec le docteur à mios puis je
pense qu'on se rapproche d'une entente
c'est de dire faisons cela pour bien
comprendre et mieux comprendre une offre
du nombre de médecins dans chacune des
régions vous vous laisserez on veut on
veut tendre et je pense que les gens
comprennent ça je pense que si on leur
prouver que c'était pas pour faire de la
coercition sur un médecin moi je
comprends ça je pense qu'une relation de
confiance qui s'est bâtie avec le
docteur agneaux depuis quelques mois
depuis son arrivée puis je pense que
tout le monde sait qu'on doit faire des
arrangements pour trouver le bon
compromis on est là dedans ce moment on
l'a vu d'ailleurs lors de votre point de
presse aujourd'hui avait des du
personnel de la santé dans la salle de
façon générale les gens avaient l'air de
vous appuyer les commentaires étaient
bons par rapport à votre plan mais il y
avait un absent ce pas le moindre c'est
la fixer tout ce qui représente
infirmières infirmiers dans leur camp
ils se disent
inquiets déçus on peut écouter ici le
président pendant bouchard
il n'y a aucun échéancier qui fait
partie de ce document et n'ont plus
aucun moyen pour arriver à ces objectifs
là alors c'est ce qui nous inquiète le
plus actuellement nous n'étions pas
partie prenante des discussions et en
aucun temps on a été consultée dans ce
plan là de refondation du réseau de la
santé
ça touche vos deux grands objectifs que
vous avez présenté dans le point de
presse en devenir un employeur attrayant
le réseau de la santé mais les
infirmières et disent écoutez on
n'élimine pas le temps supplémentaire
obligatoire on a encore recours aux
agences privées dans ce plan là elle
pourrait les agences privées sont un
énorme problème a dit cela ça provoque
un exode c'est le travail dans le public
vont vers le privé parce qu'ils trouvent
que les conditions de travail sont
meilleures alors vous améliorez vos
relations avec tout le monde dans
l'impression que toujours un gros os
avec la fiq écoutez on l'a amélioré
beaucoup avec les médecins moi je pense
qui s'est beaucoup améliorée avec
plusieurs des grandes centrales
syndicales qui était de cet après midi
vous l'avait bien dit je pense qu'il y
avait une ambiance ce matin qui étaient
fébriles les gens veulent qu'on
réussisse parce que c'est pour c'est pas
la caq 6% du bicycle des gens veulent
que le réseau de santé s'améliore les
soins de santé dans la salle du matin
maintenant particulièrement pour le fic
moi j'ai commencé à travailler avec
madame bouchard puis son équipe dans les
derniers mois parce que le remplacer
madame bédard qu'il est là
des changements c'est sûr que tout le
monde n'est pas au même endroit moi je
respecte beaucoup le milieu syndical
j'ai déjà travaillé beaucoup avec des
organisations syndicales dans ma vie en
entreprise ont chacun a son travail à
faire
moi je vous dirais un peu comme les
médecins les gens disent jamais on va
réussir à s'entendre avec les faits mais
sur le feuille deux ans ma collègue la
présidente du conseil du trésor mais
beaucoup à travailler avec la fille
qu'on a réussi madame de belles réussi à
signer une entente assez intéressant
avec la avec les infirmières il ya
encore une négociation qui s'en vient
moi je vous dirais pts et je prends dans
un environnement de coercition je suis
dans un environnement de conciliation je
vais continuer à travailler avec la fict
certain qu'on va finir par trouver des
terrains d'entente le dans les prochains
projets mois prochain album je vous
aurais bien garder plus longtemps le csb
pas j'avais beaucoup d'autres questions
mais on a une entente avec vous on doit
vous laisser filer vous avez d'autres
engagements aussi merci quand même pour
le temps vous avez je reviendrai au
brésil
au plaisir merci beaucoup merci